I'm like wow I'm just watching this as a
fan stranger things is fantastic and the
cast knows it too so today we're
checking out their passionate reactions
to season four number one we'll start
off with a scene that had us all on the
edge of our seats if gaten Matarazzo
were to use any word to describe that
mind layer scene it would definitely be
gripping watch the way this dude nibbles
on his fingernails in anticipation and
like Sadie is just so impressed by those
VFX as we know from seeing the set of
course that nothing was flying and
crashing to the ground although logic
would also tell us that we did get
really lucky this year because vekna was
pretty much fully practical effects and
with practical effects came the
possibility of scaring the Mind flares
out of the actors Jamie Campbell Bower's
chilling performance freaked out both
Sadie and Millie Bobby Brown we we can't
say we blame them on top of the
Prosthetics Jamie's keeping in character
so that he doesn't Drop The Voice or the
energy number two this scene is just
iconic even people who hate The Show
Must respect the awesome Metallica
tribute
this guitar solo was nothing short of
insane upon reading about Eddie's
ultimate fate Joseph Quinn was in his
own words gutted over not being able to
return to the show for another season
but if there's a way to go out it's a
pretty good one we have to agree there
the stakes are so high and you feel them
as an audience member Quinn never
thought he'd be able to fulfill the
Adolescent fantasy of being a rock star
it was kind of like a rock concert and I
got to feel like a rock star for one
night and Maya Hawk had of course never
seen the scene before this
we can guess by just how dropped her jaw
is was that your reaction when you saw
the scene number three if that were us
up there we think we'd have to close our
eyes I was like they're not killing you
off I was like that's dumb upon
re-watching Max's bones crack like
carrots or pieces of celery who knows
what the Foley artists were using to
make the sound effects the cast just
couldn't help but erupt into fits of
giggles
oh my God Giggles of shock mostly I was
definitely confused
um I got chills even like watching it it
must be uncomfy to watch yourself go
through that hopefully Sadie didn't
experience any Phantom Pain number four
man this scene was intense we wanted to
step in and help Caleb doesn't remember
ever reading the scene but he definitely
remembers knowing he needed to mentally
prep for it what shook him were the
interspersed stories bouncing from shot
to shot to shot but then when you see it
all come together it's like oh it was
worth it it would be seriously
underwhelming filming these scenes
without it we never quite thought about
it that way number five Finn is super
proud of improvising that you're my
superhero line it's so good buddy thank
you upon watching the scene though he
isn't looking so proud way off topic but
first thing we gotta say is if there's
ever a biopic about Johnny Depp they're
going to want Finn wolfhard to play it I
was like super scared about it so I like
ran it in my head over and over again
Finn did his best to stay stone-faced
while he watched it introvic that was
really good man and then
what totally spaced out is that because
he's so well into character or like does
he just get bored what do you think it's
almost like notebookie
number six note to Joe secure the pool
then get the lessons
Joe Kiri was a wee bit frustrated before
filming for season one ever began
because he took all these swim lessons
for his character who was supposed to be
part of a swim team but all that was cut
when they couldn't secure a pool for
filming so he was excited to finally
have the chance to work those skills he
paid for in season four getting to do
that sort of stuff is like true movie
Magic rest assured Joe always knew how
to swim he just learned how to swim
better number 7. gayton's already got
his number one Joe what would he need
enough other Joe for Gayton got a new
romance this season people loved the
Steve Dustin relationship so Joseph
Quinn found a living up to that a bit of
a challenge I was very conscious like
stepping into it and being engaged
inside Joe but he actually ended up
loving the experience because me and
Joey would just compare a little gated
anecdotes constantly somewhere
somewhere and then leaves that place
with kind of uh really dear friends what
a whole wholesome dude we're still
hoping he comes back for season five we
don't care how but he needs to reappear
number eight team tame the jungle or
team leave it alone Finn's favorite
moment from the show is probably our
favorite moment too
oh when Steve gets so hairy probably
around the same time he learned to swim
right
I keep telling him he needs to tame that
jungle but he claims the ladies dig it
something you would see in like a real
comedy movie we think Finn is having a
hard time processing that he's a real
actor on a real TV set what do you think
should Steve shave take the binoculars
and see for yourself please pause the
video if you need more time number nine
now a real question about teams Jancy or
stancy Natalia felt bad about the way
Jonathan and Steve happened she doesn't
always make like the most I don't know
morally right decisions all the time but
that's human when it comes to the
writing or even maybe when it comes to
life Natalia is a firm believer in
options I have options I guess no that's
no I'm just kidding there may have been
peer pressure involved there number 10.
sometimes it's good to get out of the
city and enjoy nature unless that nature
is the freaking desert but hey if you're
insane maybe you'll enjoy it it's it's
very cool just for me as the actor to
play in this new environment no Noah
schnapp loved filming in New Mexico in
the desert yes he loved playing around
in a new setting because he's so used to
what Hawkins looks like at this point
we're not sure what's appealing about
hanging out in the desert all day
it's a desert not a dessert it's hot
it's dusty it's Barren maybe they were
secretly tired of the rest of their
castmates number 11. long distance
relationships suck take it from us here
at the things we've never actually met
in person that is so not cool Charlie
Heaton loves the relationship challenges
his character was going through with
Nancy it's really it was really great to
kind of get to play those really cool
truths in this wild story what is sap we
are officially team Jancy sorry Steve
you had your chance and you blew it
number 12 we know what you're thinking
there's nothing more to life than pizza
and we agree I'm new to this show and
like at the same time argyle's character
is new to their crazy ass lives Eduardo
Franco feels
first time and argyle's experiencing
life-threatening situations that the
rest of the cast is almost desensitized
to it is fun that with every season new
characters are introduced to the upside
down it really creates a beautiful
contrast between the characters it's
true stranger things is an amazing show
and we've definitely binged it more than
once have you re-watched yet let us know
in the comments and thanks for hanging
out with us here at the things